wow it's weird to be in the room with
Ronnie It's the weird there he is hey
you look good pal how are you man how
are you man Miami Monday he's going to
start crying seeing me he loves it how
come I can't get that [__] greeting
well Ronnie and I Ronnie doesn't annoy
me like he didn't like you annoy me you
really don't all right sir I was pretty
depressed this morning actually I saw
your dude you know who took my place
yeah I do that Billy we yeah I was
talking to Billy and it was like dude it
was it was sad man I know he would feel
weird like being did it feel weird it
feels weird seeing you man it really
does what do you mean 30
man it's a long time to see you every
day you know for work and [__] even at a
work and it's it's just weird yeah he's
used to like doing the security and
knowing behind the scenes stuff or
whatever he doesn't have to bother or
not he doesn't have to do that anymore
yeah like just seeing it you know
everybody else handling you it it did it
bothers me yeah Billy uh Billy is my guy
yeah Billy's a good dude but I know what
you mean I knew it was going to set you
off a little bit yeah a little bit man
yeah I'm getting emotional just I'm
watching this plus I couldn't sleep last
night because I I was afraid I was
number one I was afraid I wasn't gonna
wake up right you know when you reach
your age yeah every day number two you
beat me to it yeah
number two was uh with the time change
I'm all screwed up right you know right
so I went to bed at 8 30 quarter to nine
and 11 30 I was up yeah like wide awake
and I I'm tossing I'm turning I'm trying
get up I take a piss I go back into the
bed I'm trying to go back to sleep I'm
laying this way I'm laying that way
nothing's working so Ronnie I heard a
crazy [__] story about you yeah
Stephanie was blowing Ronnie
oh you can't talk about it stop no I
want to tell you the right way okay okay
how long does it take you to come not
long really not long you exploded this
[__] guy he's 73 years old and he's
coming every minute dude I when it
happened I almost [__] passed out
like it it the intensity of the [__]
blow in my load was insane Mike what do
you think of it yeah like I said there's
nothing
elderly about Ronnie he's everything
about him is like you know he's got the
constitution of a 30 year old right 20
year old he looks he looks gentle as I
seen him but I think this is good for
him him seeing everybody and getting
back in the mix with things he's he's
it's Reviving you a little bit you're
becoming the old self that everybody
loves Mike's right the real old self wow
foreign